politics aside at the most basic level
we need to be sure we can trust that the
President of the United States is acting
in what at least they believe to be the
best interests of the country rather
than their personal best interests and
it can be hard to be sure of that so
there are some basic actions that a
president can take to at least give that
impression we need to feel like this is
the one thing that the president is
doing being president of the United
States not president of the US and a guy
who is positioning his own companies for
massive profits over the next four years
or whatever else and a picture that
surfaced recently of president-elect
Donald's daughter Ivanka Trump in a
meeting with Donald and the Prime
Minister of Japan Shinzo Abbey is deeply
disturbing on many levels can you
imagine
hi-oh mr. prime minister welcome by the
way my daughter and son-in-law will be
in the meeting she works for the Trump
Organization neither of them has a
security clearance but they'll just be
hanging out during at the meeting Ivanka
Trump is not part of the incoming
administration and she's actually banned
from being part of the administration
legally through a 1967 law which is seen
as a response to when President Kennedy
made his brother Attorney General and it
bans public officials from hiring their
relatives pretty straightforward and it
makes sense and as I mentioned in
addition to that advantage Trump has no
security clearance and as president
elect Donald is authorized to start
getting security briefings and this is
you know the conversations he's starting
to have with other world leaders are not
conversations that Ivanka Trump should
be part of but it actually goes even
further than that because Ivanka Trump
is supposedly going to be handling
Donald Trump's businesses which makes it
even more important that she not be
found anywhere near state business and
in addition to that her husband Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner was at the
meeting and all the same things I just
said about Ivanka Trump hold true about
Jared Kushner as well so what's
developing under the incoming Trump
administration is the definition of
corrupt oleg are kacal
any capitalism this is a middle finger
to the voters that were bamboozled into
voting for Trump for a change to the
status quo and for some background when
george w bush became president of the US
he liquidated his assets and he put them
in what's called a qualified diversified
trust when president obama became
president he moved his money into index
funds and government bonds basically
saying if the broader country does well
his investments will do well but he
would be hard-pressed to make individual
decisions to help his investments Trump
is said that he would put his businesses
into a blind trust but like with both
things this number one doesn't make any
sense and number two exposes that Trump
doesn't know what a blind trust is Trump
has said his kids will be running the
business Pat that means it is neither
blind nor a trust his kids are going to
be running the businesses there on the
transition team the idea is that
president-elect Donald as president
shouldn't have a connection to what is
happening with the business and
obviously there's nothing blind or
disconnected about your own kids running
the businesses the Ivanka Trump Jared
Kushner picture in the meeting with
prime minister shinzo Abbey is just all
the more disturbing excuse me well I
think the issue here is that there's no
legal obligation for you to put your
assets into a blind trust no or into
index funds right just consider the
noble and sensible thing to do right
much like releasing your tax returns is
so that the American public knows if you
have any potential conflicts of interest
yes the right thing to do and it's even
worse with Trump because he's in the
real estate business because real estate
businesses often thrive on easy money
from banks and the rates and willingness
of banks for lending are heavily
determined by broader economic policy
who President Donald appoints to certain
roles this can directly influence a
variety of interest rates which relate
to the money available to real estate
businesses now if your kids are running
your businesses that is not a blind
trust you have to hand over your assets
to a neutral third party and the
contents of the trust need to be unknown
to you and as you can imagine this is
just impossible with Donald Trump's
business situation what we're talking
about here is the possibility of a real
oleg are
right government by a few often
involving familial power and it's bad
enough when you have the president
closely tied to business interests like
for example Dick Cheney and Halliburton
and profits from the Iraq war that's bad
enough what we have with Donald Trump is
red alert I cannot possibly overstate
how dangerous this is Trump has said
there would be no conflicts of interest
which is completely laughable and there
are White House Ethics lawyers on both
sides who have said this is very
concerning now for those who voted for
Trump out of economic anxiety may be in
part anxiety caused by the idea of
Hispanic people taking your jobs but not
all how exactly are these meetings with
Shinzo ABI and Ivanka in Trump's
gold-plated Trump Tower Palace how is
this communicating Pat that things are
going to get really good soon for the
middle and lower class I'm sure they're
not I mean this is nepotism at its
finest yeah and I don't think things are
going to improve under his
administration